[موسيقى]
بين الجرتين تركيا وايران الكثير ما
يتفقوا عليه وما يختلف بشانه الملف السوري
ابرز الملفات الحاضره حاليا فبعد ان وقف
البلد على جانبي النقيض من الازمه السوريه
يعود بعض التوافق نسبيا بعد مسار دبلوماسي
تركي سوري بدا بلقاء وزيراي دفاع بلدين
اذربيجان مساحه خلاف اخرى بسبب دعمها من
قبل انقره لتخوف طهران من اغراق الممر
الحدودي بينها وبين ارمينيا والمعروف بممر
رنج روس افغانستان مساحه التنفس بين
البلدين بعناوين السياسيه امنيه واقتصاديه
ايضا في قضيه اعلان انقر القبض على شبكه
تجسس الايرانيه كانت تنوي اختطاف معارض
ايراني لتهريبه الى داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه كما تجددت خلافات قديمه بين
تركيا وايران تتعلق بالحدود اضافه الى
ازمه بناء جدران امنيه تقوم بها انقر على
الحدود الشرقيه لها مع ايران لمنع تسد
مهاجرين الافغان يضاف الى ذلك اعتراض
ايران على بناء السدود التركيه التي تمنع
تدفق المياه باتجاه ايران اقتصاديا تتطور
العلاقات حيث اعلن رئيس تركيا ان التبادل
التجاريه بين البلدين بلغ نحو سبعه
مليارات ونصف مليار دولار ويطمحان لرفعه
الى اكثر من 30 مليارا
[موسيقى]